I appreciate we've talked for about 35
minutes we have not said the two words
Donald Trump first off I think we just
had a record 35 minutes of conversation
without saying from what okay you are a
Trump supporter I'm a trumpet ear you're
a trumpet ear I think you've met with
the president right yes
how does well what can you tell me
something about him maybe that the
average person doesn't know or that you
might not get through the filter of CNN
or that you maybe don't even get through
the filter of Twitter he is somebody he
is a billionaire who left a life of
luxury to serve the American people he
is somebody who is not doing it for
power he already had power he's not
doing it for fame he already had Fame
he's not doing it for the money he
already had money he doesn't care he
wakes up every morning to all the
insults and the hate and images of
beheading by Cathy Griffiths that his
son can watch and be mortified that
somebody actually really killed my dad
and then he remembers I'm not doing this
to please the media I'm doing it because
I'm fighting for the American people
they hate him not because they hate him
because he is serving the American
people he is putting America first and
they do not know how to handle him and
that's why Donald Trump is resonating
with a lot of people in this country
from CEOs of companies the janitors
working for $10 an hour because from the
janitor to the CEO they know and
everybody in between president Donald
Trump is working for me and it's a
breath of fresh air because for decades
now we have had many presidents on the
right and the left not many people could
say Barack Obama is working for me
or George Bush is working for me or
Clinton is working for me but with
Donald Trump
the janitor knows President Donald Trump
is working for me and that's why he's
resonating with the people
so when you see the the tweets and some
of the over-the-top stuff you know every
now and again I'll watch some old clips
from him in the 80s talking to Oprah or
Phil Donahue and he's he's soft and and
seemingly you know very pleasant and
open and you can see the way in Q&A is
with audience members I think on Donahue
he's extremely human all of these things
and it's not exactly the caricature that
we get these days do you think that he
sort of became this thing because it was
the only he basically was the it was the
only way he would have been hard enough
to break through does that make sense
like I think he was probably extremely
similar to the person from back then but
he became hardened because it was the
only way you were gonna ever break
through this like no one else was ever
gonna break through this thing if you
listen to a very confident but you know
what I got the point
if you Donald Trump today is the exact
same person he was 25 years ago when he
wasn't Phil Donahue when he wasn't Oprah
he still says the exact same words have
you noticed well the theme is the same
but he's he's hardened now there's like
and I don't know I'm not even blaming
him for that I think to go through this
to go through the media machine and the
establishment and all that you you've
got to get hardened otherwise it will
choke everybody out which is we need
fight to win before they didn't argue
with what he said so you didn't see that
side of him he would have been just as
hard back then today they do not want to
listen to any words he says if he became
Jesus they would find the reason to
fight against him they would call him
you know evil hater monster whatever
whatever whatever so the reason why they
call him all the names that they call
him now is because he is not toeing the
line to them look he has ninety million
followers on Twitter he goes straight
around the media he doesn't need the
media he is communicating directly with
the American people and the media hates
this and he is somebody who fights the
breath I love his tweets by the way you
know I know it makes a lot of people
uncomfortable oh my god I cannot believe
he tweeted that you know what we finally
have a man who stands up to the bullies
and punches back we are so used to men
who are wusses in this country we have
forgotten what it's like to see a real
man
who stands up and says I respect myself
too much to let you walk all over me or
call me that or treat me that way but if
you treat me that way I'm gonna punch
you back now stand up like a man and
fight me
we forgot how a man like that looks like
and so Donald Trump is shocking the
system at a time where men have been
stripped out of their manhood they you
know the society is changing you know
roles are changing so in our society
today they want the man that they can
walk all over and you know they say oh
we need somebody who is nice and you
know like Romney or like McCain you know
everybody loved McCain until he ran for
president then they did the same thing
to him everybody loved Romney and
thought he ran for president they did
the same thing to him I mean if you
would hear CNN talk about Romney or
McCain when they were running for
president yeah they were saying the same
thing versus he hated women all of those
things so I'm completely with you on
that part that's what I mean by the the
hardening of trunk that he almost had to
be this thing because nobody else could
have they tried it the other way they
tried it with night you know nicer
people so to speak yeah and it just
doesn't work so it's like well this is
this is the guy you're gonna get and
he's getting things done and the
American people are behind him and he is
resonating with the American people and
if his message wasn't resonating he
wouldn't have the tens of millions of
followers who are following him on
social media and still rooting for him
and the Donald Trump supporters dig
their Hill even deeper with all the
attacks from the media with even the
attacks from his own party Dave I mean
look you and I know there are people who
hate his guts on Washington DC you talk
about cleaning the swamp he is shaking
everybody the left and the right despite
all that his support his approval rating
is that an all-time high you know so it
doesn't matter what people are saying to
him he is doing what is right by the
American people by America so what are
some of the policies that he's doing
that that jive with this book like in
terms of borders and stuff like that
you're you're for building the wall
absolutely yeah absolutely and here is
why I am illegal immigrant to the United
States
I understand what it's like for people
to want to come here I wanted to come
here so badly
I remember getting an American flag
putting it under my pillow and my bomb
shelter and I couldn't wait to come to
America I learned English I don't know
if I shared with you this with you last
time writing subtitles on my arm did I
tell you that's how I learned English I
never studied English at school I was so
determined to come to the United States
that we would watch black-and-white
television operated on a car battery in
our bomb shelter and my father would
watch the news and if there was any
charge of the battery left
I would watch The Love Boat on Wednesday
night and Dallas on Friday night and you
know we would have every diet what
America that's what impacted my life and
and if two people looked into each
other's eyes and you know he said
something to her and she said maybe and
they would write what maybe were met on
the bottom I knew that maybe meant
whatever that word in Arabic and I would
literally write it in ink on my arm and
because we barely had water to drink let
alone shower we showered once a week I
felt the huge vocabulary on my arm
that's how I learned English because I
was so determined that if I ever meet an
American I want to be able to be able to
communicate with them in their language
so I can get to the United States and
when I came to the United States
I came to America by marriage I had
married an American a war correspondent
in Jerusalem we came to America we put
in my papers to become an American I
flew here I paid for my airline ticket
paid for my attorneys to do all my
paperwork paid for my doctor's visit to
do all the needle poking to make sure
I'm tested for this disease and that
disease to make sure I'm not bringing
anything to the country and then I had
to study a 2-inch thick book written by
the Daughters of the American Revolution
about America's history and heritage and
pass a written exam as well as a verbal
exam in English before I became an
American about America's history by the
time I became an American I knew more
about America's history than my own
american-born husband did I am a legal
immigrant those are the type of
immigrants we need coming to America
because we had a fire in our belly to be
all we can be as Americans
now the people who are breaking the law
to get here not because they want to
come here for a better life or they are
escaping persecution look at the caravan
that's coming to the United States
Mexico offered them asylum Mexico
offered them jobs they didn't want it
they're not there to seek jobs or asylum
they you and they passed literally by UN
centers set up specifically for those
who want asylum and claiming refugee
status they didn't even stop continued
coming to the United States to the
border and not even to the bar port of
entry just to break the law to get here
we have to have law and order in the
country so yes I support Donald Trump
build the wall and make sure anybody who
wants to come to the United States can
go through the proper channel and earn
the privilege to be an American because
it is a privilege because people like me
who did it by the book are insulted and
offended when we see criminals are
allowed to come in here and have the
same rights that we paid with our sweat
heart and blood to get and work very
hard for years to become Americans yeah
that's so fascinating to me because
they've also done plenty of studies on
this where recent immigrants are
actually against the caravan and against
well not because they have anything
against the people but if you did it the
right way right if you did it the way
the law lays out well then you don't
want people just just storming over and
that's that is what a nation of laws is
right and you know when you look at what
the legal immigration is costing the
United States do you know that forty
five billion dollars a year
leaves America from those illegal aliens
that come here to work in the United
States that legal criminal aliens and
they sent it to their countries of
origin that money is not staying here
they're not here to become a part of the
American fabric to contribute to
American society to grow to become all
they can be they are here to use our
system and siphon money and send it out
there do you know that it costs the
American public two hundred billion
dollars a year in welfare expenses by
criminal illegal aliens to the United
States three million illegal aliens are
incarcerated
early in American prisons 30% of federal
inmates and federal prisons are illegal
criminal aliens so when you look at the
cost when you add all the costs and it
can rattle in a bunch of points but when
you add it all up 338 billion dollars a
year is the cost of illegal immigration
to the United States the cost bill the
wall is nothing compared to what we're
paying annually in a lift illegal
criminal aliens not to mention the
crimes killing our children ms-13 gang
come in here and what they're doing to
our society we don't want any of that
what are you making the same people who
will tell you that America is an evil
patriarchal capitalistic monster that
also want open borders to apparently
share in that horror with everybody else
America pretty flood thinking there
would yeah absolutely
America is the most incredible nation on
the face of the planet
look you traveled the world you're
traveling on a speaking tour I was born
and raised on the other side of the
world I understand I've seen you and I
have travelled the world I mean from
Australia to Europe I mean we've been in
a lot of places you and I and we have
seen how the other the rest of the world
lives compared to the rights that we
have here look our poorest of the poor
who are living on welfare have
dishwashers in their government paid
housing have heating and
air-conditioning have cell phones you
know these are luxury items for and many
other places in the rest of the world
even in developed country there are
considered luxury items this is what we
give to people who are living on welfare
in the United States so those who
complain about America need to open
their eyes they need to go to India you
know to the slums of India they need to
visit the Philippines they need to go to
Vietnam they need to go to Egypt they
need to see how the rest of the world
lives and then come back to American
complain isn't it just a lazy way of
thinking really because it's just easier
to destroy them create so it's just
easier to sit here after all of the
hard-won freedoms and tell you how
horrible everything is rather than
actually fix anything but burning things
down is a lot easier right exactly
exactly and they and but no one's
holding them accountable you see people
like us and the old great generation who
really fought World War two
or the veterans are still walking among
us today who fought you know in the wars
whether in Korea or in Vietnam on World
War two I mean now they're getting older
and fewer and dying but their
descendants so understand what America
did to the world and the freedoms that
we helped spread around the world look
we didn't want anything from the Japan
you know we conquered nation and then we
gave them their freedom and then rebuild
them who does that we didn't go to Iraq
because we wanted oil we didn't go to
Afghanistan because we wanted the oil we
went there and started building schools
and bridges for them to improve their
lives and love them didn't take any of
the oil with us we want to improve the
world and we need to fight right now
those lazy American brats who are
speaking else of America who I do not
understand America we need to come
together organize and rise rise together
in defense of America and that's why we
need to come together and understand
what we are facing how we are losing our
country and this is what I get to in the
book you know I say how did we go from
the stories of George Washington and the
cherry tree I shall never tell a lie how
did we go from that generation to the
antifa thugs who were born and raised in
America went to American schools paid
for by our tax dollars who believed you
can cheat you can lie you can steal you
can show up with machetes you are and
and brass knuckles you can hit people
you can block bridges you can destroy
property and you feel justified doing it
how did we go in one generation and one
lifetime from this to that and that's
why we need to stand up those of us who
are in the middle who understand America
greatness need to come together and
stand up to fight to protect America
while we still have a chance so what are
the other judeo-christian values that we
need to be thinking about we talked
about free speech what are the other
bedrock principles that we need to fight
back some of this stuff oh my goodness
we need to fight to protect our language
yeah explain something very easy to you
you we cannot lose our language language
unites people in one nation the English
language right now we are importing
people from different parts of the world
and we are not making them learn English
we now have public schools that have 16
different languages that are spawning in
a public school and
teachers who have to be trained to speak
a certain language to children instead
of saying okay no you came to America me
to assimilate you need to learn English
I know Spanish people who have been in
this country Mexican people for over 20
years they still cannot speak English
properly or they speak very little
English that's not acceptable that's not
what made America great we have got to
enforce that English is the official
language of the United States and shall
remain so we welcome people from all
backgrounds the immigrants that came to
this country back the Jews that came
from all over the world the Irish the
Catholics the everybody they came to the
United States they made sure their
children spoke English because they
wanted their kids to become as American
as apple pie as fast as possible to
assimilate into this society we're not
seeing that right now we are seeing in
Detroit you call government office
you're getting in Arabic you know and
then you push like for for English but
first you get Arabic and then you get
Spanish and then you get this and this
and that that's unacceptable
and people need to understand their
power and my book at the end of every
chapter I have a section titled rise up
and act no matter what I'm talking about
I give people ideas and tips three
things you can do under 10 minutes that
will make a difference for the country
and you can do them sipping your cup of
coffee and your pajamas at 7:00 a.m. in
the morning to give you an idea calling
your elected official many people say
Bridget what is my voice gonna count my
elected official needs to hear from
40,000 people before they do something
wrong I talk to elected officials all
the time and I ask them how many people
do you need to hear from about a single
issue to make it your top priority
you'll be shocked how many do you think
I mean it's got to be so ridiculously
low because nobody calls them and we all
think it's 40,000 but it's probably like
50 people or something that's it 40 to
50 people and here is the science behind
the numbers they believe if one person
makes a phone call or writes a letter he
or she are representing 1,000 couch
potatoes who feel the same way but are
too lazy to make a phone call or write a
letter yet they vote on Election Day
that translates to 40 to 50,000 voters
on Election Day that can make or break
an election so I tell people you can be
active
sitting in traffic look we are in LA how
many hours people spend sitting on
traffic I spent two and a half hours
yesterday sitting in traffic trying to
go 50 miles yeah program the White House
phone number program your elected
officials phone number in your in your
cell phone when you get a text alert
from us about a bill coming down for
about punch a button click and call your
elected officials or send an email when
people got to act for america.org which
I mentioned all throughout the book my
organization act for america.org they
can click on contact Congress they can
sign up to get our emails and action
alerts we send emails about bills coming
down for a vote the bill number who
sponsors it well it says we even have
pre-written letters for them that they
can email they're electro fischels with
the click of a button it'll go to your
elected official letters to the editors
script I give samples in this book the
last chapter the whole chapter is
samples about activism samples about
letters to the editor all you have to do
is add your name and send it to your
newspaper it's part of the problem that
we put so much emphasis on the
presidency so it's great you're doing
local activism you're saying call your
Congressman if you've got a problem with
your exit my exit right here where I
live I don't want to say exactly where
it's filled with garbage for the two
years that I've been living here David's
been calling this guy non-stop to get
that he wants to go out there and start
picking up stuff but it's too dangerous
but it's just but like nobody focuses on
local anymore because we put such
emphasis on the executive branch on the
cult of personality around the
presidency so it's like by going to your
local congressman or congresswoman you
might actually get something done it's a
lot harder to do it the other way
absolutely and and on the local sit
elected officials you know the your
local state and delegates I may have you
call the guy 10 to 12 people that's it
and so this is why we started chapters
nationwide this is why we have activists
nationwide I tell people go to act for
america.org sign up as an activist join
a chapter or start a chapter if there's
no chapter near you everything happens
on a local level because those local
elected officials that you develop a
connection within a contact go to become
state elected officials then federal
elected officials Attorney General's and
then state Senators Congressmen
is how we change society and so I
encourage people to get involved and
become engaged and that's exactly what
this this book is a roadmap for people
on how to rise rise this is right back
we titled it rise we will need to get
this book and they need to donate it to
every library in their community so when
people are looking to find out
information they can find it read it for
yourself donate it to a public library
in your community get multiple copies we
want people to learn how they can be
mobilized the left understands how to
mobilize we on the right understand the
issues but do not know how to mobilize
and that's what this book teaches them
so what what else what else can we do I
feel like you got a couple other tricks
up your sleeve oh absolutely
give me something sexy you can't just be
calling your Congressman make new
friends if find out I start a chapter
you'll get to meet the great new friends
in your community if people sign up to
be a chapter leader with us we will
connect them with the same group in
their local community who sign up to get
our emails and they say I want to join a
chapter I want to meet people in my
community like this we connect them
together they can do local activities
together they can go out to dinners
together they can work on issues
relating to their community I have found
I have made the best friends doing my
activism that's what launched my career
in activism so this is the type of ideas
that people can do come together and
work together have already Saturday one
Saturday have a meeting a chapter
meeting once a month write letters to
your Congressman about the garbage on
the side of the street you know we need
to clean this garbage out this is
unacceptable protest builds that are
coming down I'll give you an idea we're
accepting all these refugees coming in
here so right now we are bringing our
standards down to accommodate the
standards of people from third-world
country to give you an example the city
of Denver in 2017 passed an ordinance
that allowed people to defecate on the
sidewalk why because they have a lot of
illegal immigrants who feel no problem
to just drop their pants and do it on
the side of the road but because it is a
deportable crime because that crime is
punishable up to one year in jail
and if you commit such a crime you are
deported the city of Denver has a bigger
problem with illegal immigration than
San Francisco and Philadelphia so that's
why they passed the ordinance they do
not want people deported can you imagine
if you have a chapter with 30 people or
30 people Argan izing together on the
same issue calling your their local
state government saying this is
unacceptable and if you don't change
that we're gonna vote you out and
replace you that's how the left does it
that's how we need to do it that's a
pretty clear one where you could
probably escape some of the cries of
racism right because nobody wants their
streets filled up with poopit you know
San Francisco has this app that will
tell you where human poop is
unbelievable and now the diseases that
are spreading because of that and this
is something I mentioned in the book all
the rise in diseases in our country you
know you've heard look right now but the
Lyme disease or that disease that's not
being trend transferred to people
because in San Francisco if that flies
basically eating the human waste and
then you're walking down the street and
they're biting you
so mosquitoes now are transferring these
diseases that were once eliminated in
the United States but simply eating
human waste and I'm biting you with it
putting it in your body this is exactly
why about a month ago we started seeing
you know this disease pop up people
cannot explain it some people died
tuberculosis for example is exploding in
the United States the top four states
with tuberculosis are California over
500 cases Florida Texas and New York 16
states are now grappling with
tuberculosis it is the fastest growing
disease in America right now they have
the state of Wisconsin alone has a
hundred and sixteen cases of
tuberculosis and the majority of them
are drug-resistant
which means it takes six months to treat
a patient and it takes six to eight
months to treat them at the cost of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
patient out of our tax dollars these are
issues we need to talk about these are
issues affecting our communities and
that's what I discuss in the book so
it's not only about national security
per se it's why we need to rise in
defense of our culture and our freedoms
and what made America great do you find
that the people that are part of act are
diverse
because it's so it's interesting I mean
I've spent hours with you now and it's
like I guess you're a conservative but
you're not you're sort of my kind of
conservative your husband is your friend
right but you're really you're like my
kind of liberal which which you know is
half conservative at this point because
everything is so upside down but do you
find that you get a real mix of
political views in the people that are
coming to you oh my gosh
absolutely look with our organizations I
mean we have everybody people that put
their differences aside and came
together for the safety and security of
America and preserving who we are as
Americans and defending our American
values
our members are Jews Christians
Buddhists Hindus atheist gays lesbians I
mean AGGA gay chapter leaders priests
chapter leaders we've got everybody
people like you and I and everybody else
that put yeah you know people may not
agree on every single social issues but
people agree on a lot of things that
make us Americans because we love each
other as Americans we respect each other
as Americans and we want to defend our
country and the principles that made it
great and so that's why we work together
and it's like I said it's such a shame
that now people you know say I never
thought I would be you know I would be
called a conservative or you would be
called a conservative but you know what
as far as the left is concerned right
now you and I are conservatives yeah
that doesn't matter that you are a
married gay man yeah you're a
conservative welcome to the new
conservatism and you know this is why
what Donald Trump talks about
nationalism we are in nationalist
country we are we are standing up as a
nation to fight what makes America great
patriotic America you know the
patriotism that we have in America they
don't have in other countries of the
world you go to Australia you don't see
the Australian flag flying everywhere
you go to England you don't see that in
British flag front no I really noticed
that when I was in there now that you're
travelling worldwide
what makes America so
unique is this nationalism that brings
us all together our love for country
people got to baseball to games and we
played the national anthem you know they
don't do that in other parts of the
world they don't play the national
anthem before games we take it for
granted and now everybody's upset with
the president because he's talking about
American nationalism what brings us
together they need to travel to
Australia go to Canada go to Germany
attend a a a a football thing they don't
play the national anthem it's not like
the United States that's what he was
referring to we're talking about our
nationalism what brings us together as
Americans our Americanism he could have
used the different word Americanism so
the word so the left would not feel
offended but that's what he was talking
about pretty sure they would have
offended either way they would have been
offended either way I feel I should give
you the chance to close this with the
speech as epic as your last although
you've done about five of them here in
the last hour but you want to give me a
closing statement that will be me mobile
footprints and history are not made
sitting down countries cannot be saved
by hashtags and tweets we need to stand
up and put some sweat equity into saving
our country but thankfully we don't have
to freeze and Valley Forge like our
founding fathers in the snow waiting to
see if we still have a country the next
day what we can do right now with our
activism is come together and get
together at a coffee shop sipping our
cappuccinos meeting like-minded great
American soul of America who believe in
America's exceptionalism who believe in
safe secure border who believe in having
law and order in our country who believe
in respecting our police who believe in
honoring our military who believe in
cherishing the memories and and and and
acknowledging the freedom that we have
and the sacrifices that our military
have paid to give us the freedoms that
we have today you know when we visit
other countries and you have visited
France and you go to Normandy and you
see the graves of Americans in Normandy
you sit back and you know that these
American brave soldiers left their home
and went overseas laying their life on
the line to fight for freedom and for
justice and for the American values if
you don't want to call them
judeo-christian values American values
so the rest of the world can experience
the freedom that we have the previous
generation was willing to cross oceans
and go die over there to protect the
same freedoms that we have here at home
and give them to other people the least
we can do is activate here in our home
in the United States of America and come
together and stand together and face
those naysayers and those who slap
labels on us at least they're not
shooting bullets at us all they all
they're saying is ah he's a racist or
she's a racist or she's a white
supremacist but we can come together to
save our country together and that's the
beauty it's people like you and I coming
together and looking into each other's
eyes and really being so excited to see
each other again and be together again
as Americans as different as we are but
we come together and we love each other
and respect what each other does to save
this country and that's what America is
all about I encourage people to rise
rise in defense of judeo-christian
values and freedom get the book read it
share it with their friends get multiple
copies put them in public libraries we
need to educate and go to act for
America that on and by the way we named
the organization act for America now
think about America now wish for America
not pray for America you can do all that
but without acting nothing happens you
are the real deal Brigitte you are the
racist bigot of the day that I will
gladly be thrown in that bucket with you
you in case people don't know guys the
link to rise is right down below and buy
it and put it in libraries and all that
to help us for more regime you can
follow her on Twitter it's act Bridget
[Music]